[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: At Google, our
services and products
run on a globally-distributed
computing system
made up of many machines
and data centers.
They're all linked to a
large-scale network that's
core to what makes Google
services, including Google
Cloud, run.
So how does Google's data
center networking work?
First, you need to understand
the size of our network.
Google's network
supports a 1 petabyte
per second
bisectional bandwidth.
To put that in perspective,
you could transfer the entirety
of Wikipedia in under a
second, or enough bandwidth
to read the entire
scanned contents
of the Library of Congress in
less than 1/10 of a second.
While I could talk
about the fiber
optic cables or physical
switches we use,
the real power comes from how
we manage traffic at scale.
See, the networking
between data centers
is built with diverse
pathways of fiber
interconnecting data
centers, points of presence,
or local network access
points, and even continents
through subsea cables.
We need to ensure
data centers can
talk to each other
for resilience
so we can serve traffic close
to our users and customers.
To do that, we use our
global wide area network.
Our goal is to create enough
redundancy and capacity
of the overall network to reduce
traffic congestion in any one
area and withstand
any network failures.
That's why at our
data centers, we've
invested in not just one
fiber link out of a building,
but many fiber links to provide
more paths and redundancy
to our long-haul network
or wide area network.
So what's happening
within the data centers
once traffic passes
through these links?
Our data center network
fabric is made up
of a closed hierarchical
switching fabric we designed
called Jupiter, which
connects hundreds of thousands
of machines across
data center buildings.
Machines at the data center
have physical connections,
or switching, into
Jupiter, and all traffic
flowing through
Jupiter is controlled
by a central
software-defined controller.
Jupiter's able to provide such
large bandwidth because it's
nonblocking, which
means it can handle
routing a request to
any free output port
without interfering
other traffic.
This means it can scale or
burst with extremely low latency
and is capable of
building resilience.
If something in
the fabric breaks,
it can handle disruptions.
So where does Google Cloud
traffic fit into all of this?
Andromeda is a virtualized
software-defined network
built on top of
Jupiter, giving you
your very own slice of our
massive global switching
fabric.
Andromeda enables you to
deploy a virtual private cloud
network, giving you both
functional and performance
isolation and a high
degree of security.
With its global control
plane, high speed
on-host virtual switch,
and packet processors,
you can burst thousands
of stateful machines
online in minutes or
deploy firewall rules
across thousands of
machines immediately
without chokepoints.
And because Compute and
Storage are separated and talk
to each other
through the network,
they can scale
independently so you
get virtually unlimited
storage and stateless
resilient compute.
Whether you're processing
petabytes of data
in seconds using BigQuery,
running consistent databases
across regions using Spanner,
or autoscaling GKE clusters
across zones, Google's data
centers and global network
backbone together make these
technologies impressive.
If you want to learn
more, check out
cloud.google.com/networking.